all right let's get some food yeah what
are we doing here that whole thing is a
Monumental podcast that we have to frame
off of like like it's Monumental that is
a rare instance where I show my
intellect twice a year I like to remind
people like I'm not a [ __ ] Joker hey
everyone what you're about to watch is
Gary and some fellow speakers having a
combo about nft utility right after the
brand Minds event in Bucharest Romania
for anyone that's still skeptical about
nfts or still having a tough time
understanding the point of nfts I think
this video is really going to help you
let's take this extraordinary
family yes in Milwaukee Wisconsin I love
this I love the question already middle
class keep going middle class upper
middle class yes
how are they going to own and use nft
their their favorite coffee shop that
sells them seven dollar latte right the
punch card that gives them an 11th free
coffee will be an nft in a decade
and let me keep playing let me keep
playing
follow-up so it's a way to it's a way to
improve ownership and put utility
against it okay but so what it's doing
is it's is actually making more
efficient something that people are
already doing correct but let me keep
going okay go go go now the coffee shop
owner in Milwaukee yeah is quite
Progressive okay and decided that the
artist of the of the coffee punch card
yeah is going to be a uh Inner City
child from the bad parts of Milwaukee
who's a great who they just did a
contest and they won and the month of
April February for Black History Month
is this artist the 16 year old nine
years later goes on to be a commercially
successful artist right
the first art that he has ever made on
the blockchain happens to be a Milwaukee
coffee shop collectors like me that
collect this and millions of other
things go and start buying that nft for
two thousand dollars because it's his
rookie nft
rendering an eight percent commission
fee to the Milwaukee coffee shop that's
sharing it with Tyrone four and four and
rendering me to wake up one day reading
a headline and saying wait a minute I
have that NFP because I used to go to
it's creating infrastructure that people
can't see yet that's a beautiful example
of the mundane SMB normal person every
airline ticket is right now a QR code
right all three of us grew up when that
was a piece of paper right in between it
was a email and many other things right
that also will be every corporation has
okay so agendas for art that they can
you know if you look at so that's where
I think it's going
is uh he is at least to me it's like not
making more efficient something that
already exists but this idea that you
can the idea that you can do something
that isn't possible today correct it's
gonna be both yeah right so so what is
impossible today is this idea that you
can have essentially I mean you think
about with art like you can have
essentially the the the the the
Providence of the Art built into the art
itself so correct exactly where it is
and the other thing is that you can
actually give the artist humor herself a
cut of the secondary Market it's absurd
it changes everything because because I
think California has a law to require in
that so if I buy a pizza if I buy a
painting from Angela all right and then
Angela becomes famous I buy a painting
from Angela when she is unknown correct
and it's a thousand dollars happens all
the time and then Angela becomes
incredibly famous correct then I sell
that painting for a hundred thousand
dollars she doesn't get anything that's
right although under California law
there's some kind of Vision that
requires I'd love to know how and well
that's being enforced exactly correct
that's the problem that's and that's the
correct correct that's
that's you know what else is amazing
that is true
it think about how people are going to
fund their music projects think about
how an artist music artist today does it
they sign a contract with a record label
for distribution right
they're basically getting uh 20 cut
after they pay back the bank
all their dollars
for the most successful it becomes an
atrocious deal which is why you've seen
from Prince on through the decades I've
said now let me play it a different way
imagine nirvana in 1992
had social media and on Tick Tock says
our first album's coming out and all the
fans that have been following us on Tick
Tock you can buy an nft that represents
a percentage of the back and in
perpetuity now okay isn't this is this
isn't that profound now I'm getting
Goosebumps now you know this fans hate
when their banned or artist gets famous
because they sold out and they can't go
see them when there's only 50 people in
it now fans are gonna make their wealth
from their favorite Brands making it
interesting isn't that fascinating
interesting
could one do the same thing for
actors of course so you're basically
just what about what about people what
about people what about Harry Potter or
I'll give you a great one I argue that
if nft was mature in 1975 that George
Lucas would be the richest person on
earth
because every single collectible in
digital form giving George Lucas a
percentage of not only the primary but
the secondary trip are you kidding me
yeah I mean look at eBay right now and
see how many tickets from concerts and
sporting events are sold a year stubs
every ticket's gonna be an nft within a
half a decade rendering the NBA
Alicia Keys and many others getting in
perpetuity royalties for collectors that
now eBay and FedEx make money on not
them
and so it is a profound technology that
people are just starting to have the
conversations in rooms like this that
we're having which I've only felt in my
short career in 96 7 about the internet
and 2005 six seven about social media
but you're but you're bullish about not
about digital currency but about digital
assets that have utility attached
I'm not not bullish on currency I'm just
not educated enough and haven't seen the
path and I think government has to
accept too much and private business has
to accept too much and there's a lot
more friction whereas with nfts
entrepreneurs and creatives
and operators and audiences can now act
today which has a lot less friction than
a government accepting Bitcoin as a as a
Fiat
how much friction is there like what the
form of ownership for civilians go back
to this family in Milwaukee yes
ownership is a wallet yeah right
tremendous friction the reason this
hasn't become hundreds of millions yet
is the onboarding no different than our
parents putting a credit card into a
computer in 1996 and being scared that
it would be stolen if you remember those
days
or my mother in 2022. Fair yeah or us
even figuring I mean I was a curious kid
and just didn't understand Prodigy I
didn't know how to get on the internet
and then Mark Andreessen created
Netscape Navigator and typing in a
address and enter so we are still to
your point and I love the question it is
even for me two years ago when I'm like
I'm going in it was like this is not so
easy what's a seed phrase and being a
custodial owner of your state it was a
lot of friction right over the next
decade that will become the mundane and
that's when it will explode I think the
analogy is really interesting that I had
thought about before is there a mosaic
yeah of course of course I believe what
I talked about today on stage was this
concept of web 2.5 everyone's talking
two and three I think there's a chapter
here in the next three to five years and
I've I've actually been bullish coinbase
even though they got lots of problems
given how overvalued the stock was and
where they're at right now I believe in
their CEO and I actually think they're
the most positioned to create what I
call a web 2.5 where they are the holder
of the assets so it is actually against
the philosophy of web 3. the philosophy
of web 3 is do not allow corporations or
others to have control the problem is
everybody loves the Wild Wild West which
that is until you're the one getting
shot so I've watched people on Twitter
go crazy and be web 3 Maxis and be like
this is the best [ __ ] the government
[ __ ] the corporations and then they get
their nft stolen and immediately they're
like hey government hey Corporation and
so here right and so we're gonna go
through this path but I think your
um intuition on that Insight is right I
do think that the next decade is about
education and innovators whether on the
corporate side or the entrepreneurial
side of eliminating friction for the day
to day but but much like in 1995 where I
was a kid and really wasn't a technology
kid what I knew is that people were
gonna use this damn thing
because it was just gonna change
everything that's kind of in the same my
first it's interesting my first
email account was a CompuServe account
so you were there I don't know yeah of
course I do my first email was that 9234
it was like 94 . yeah it makes sense my
first email address was something like
seven four six two nine eight five phone
number oh it wasn't even that oh just
some numbers yeah at compuserve.com I
think mine was gnuts at aol.com
friends who are like I would call us
purple we're not red we're using
political standards we're not red or
blue on this thing and web3 we're purple
we're in the middle we're we're very
bullish yeah but we're not like the
metaverse is here tomorrow it's all
about timing right when we have
thoughtful combos where we're being
thoughtful we always talk about what's
the AOL moment which organization which
entrepreneur is going to come along and
create an onboarding that makes a lot
that makes a lot more sense but but what
will happen in that very quickly just to
give you the big butt is a lot of people
will realize wait a minute this isn't
actually web3 this isn't blockchain
because the hypothesis is
decentralization
creates no power for anyone what we're
talking about right now is web25
something that somebody is still in
power of
and and what you know what I like about
it I like a world of a mature web25 and
a real web 3 because then you're giving
people options hey do you want to live
in web 3 where hey by the way it's all
on you you better know your [ __ ] you
better know how it works and you have
the option hey you're a little worried
about that you're you're a little Tech
nervous you're not there yet use this
web25 and that's what I think the next
decade's about but for math for Mass
adoption civilians are going to be
indifferent whether it's what 2.5
they're going to be web 25 because web3
is gonna be too complicated yeah well
they just they want they want look look
at social media when I was all done hoe
in 0506 it took a while we have that
full adoption in 2022. most people have
some account Facebook LinkedIn Twitter
something and I think that is inevitable
for web 3 but it will be uh will be a
decade and a half a decade and two
decades but when it's but starting a
year ago to that time every day things
are getting innovated and changing and
the opportunity is extraordinary the
opportunity in web 2 from 2005 to 2020
was extraordinary Facebook Instagram
Uber seamless I mean just everything we
know Spotify I mean name something I'll
tell you something that happened in 15
years the same thing's about to happen
and the accelerant there was
correct
this is now in place though for web 3.
back to the coffee shop right to your
point
the accelerator to the Moon of this this
is actually the most this is actually
the most
[Music]
is actually thinking analogically about
this and saying what is the Netscape
Navigator what is the AOL what is the
thing that's going to move it from I
mean I you know I I remember like I'm
old enough to remember Prodigy yeah um
I'm old enough I'm 46 how old are you
I'm I'm 10 years older than her first of
all you look phenomenal second of all
second of all you you and I I would
still argue that we're in that same
sphere yeah that that generation in my
opinion and this is what I have a lot of
friends going on this thing called the
internet and it was just it was like on
an MS-DOS computer yeah and like and
like looking around and saying well this
is this is kind of it was profound why
are these people out there it was
profound that is what's happening now
yeah and and to that point you have to
be extreme but to that point it's a it's
a small sliver of people correctly but
here's where I get really passionate
so many of my contemporaries 45 to 55
who are thoughtful enough to have this
exact combo yeah I argue with them and
motivate them and encourage them I'm
like you know better you actually lived
this old movie already you remember 1990
to 2000 you should actually have more
ferocity to be curious but a lot of
people are complacent it's a lot of work
it's a listen I spent a hundred hours
which is Meaningful time
just watching the same 101s to get to
these hypothesis I love being a
communicator and a translator when you
just said what you said that means the
world to me you don't understand that
that is such an invigorating comment
what's the best thing to watch and read
on this short of having a conversation
with you send me an email let's get
let's get each other's information but
but yeah because I'll send you a bunch
of links yeah all right in the old days
it was possible to
um a boxer you might know this boxers
who create professional boxes would
create what's called a syndicate
and Syndicate was essentially that they
would get investors in their career
and the investors in their career would
essentially Finance the training that's
right in exchange for a piece of the
person Mike Tyson well and I always not
only the 20s up to Mike Tyson and I've
been waiting for 20 years for that
that's the technology that exists
waiting for that I'm waiting like why
would why would
but but I'm wondering whether let me let
me let me jump in let me jump in uh
there is a gentleman uh I want to give
you his name Jesus I'm blanking ah God I
know so well we went to Facebook forever
he'll come to me in a second
[ __ ] I could see his face uh he sending
a startup that is built on the
blockchain that allows human beings to
come in
and sell a piece of their life earnings
and the technology infrastructure is
absurd yeah
it's amazing but I mean but that's
amazing right and you know why because
we're getting The Upfront economics I
think I'm talented and if you think
about it this is why I'm very passionate
about the blockchain let me give you a
great analogy on this one let's say
you're a kid from the other side of the
tracks
right and you don't have a network
but you have all the black and white
Talent
if you think about that trade I'm that
person
if I can get two hundred thousand
dollars up front I may not have to slug
away a decade
if I give up 10 of my earnings if I'm
that talent for two hundred thousand
dollars today
think about on both sides for the kid
that's a good trade quality of your life
maybe about ability to go do what they
really want to do instead of giving up a
decade to get to The Leverage on the
other side someone like me if I see the
town especially me because I was a kid
from the other side that's my most
interesting thing that's an incredible
Financial investment these are profound
changes and when and when the government
is on the blockchain and think about
where you're going with the California
thing when that kid really goes on to be
that kid I'm getting a piece of his
income tax statement sure he could play
a little bit here and there but that's
going to be attached to that contract
you're actually as the investor gonna
get your money yeah it's really big
technology
and that's a really fun one right and
you know what that does that changes
Society now all of a sudden you know
what a decentralized server base creates
is some of the promises that a lot of us
have wanted for the world it gives us
another tool
to make social change
and that's exciting
yeah and I like the internet
describing is essentially a Syndicate
for everybody correct everybody and
everything well but the other thing
about that is that it opens up some
interesting it opens up into using
ecosystem well what it really does is it
puts pressure on governments which is
why
well The Syndicate for human beings
they're thinking for human beings
creates a peer-to-peer infrastructure
that starts to really question a lot of
things that sit in the middle like
governments uh I'll give you a great
example I can't today and it's early see
a world where people don't buy each
other's homes off of each other through
the blockchain and nothing's in the
middle of it
nothing meaning like the friction
creators like like mortgage insurance
and closed title I mean title would be a
perfect example titles title ready title
companies what I felt ready Title
Insurance ready you ready you ready you
ready what I felt about bookstores in
1995 because I was really in it I was
really in it at that point I was like
they're in deep [ __ ] I even like had one
friend's family and I'm like I'm telling
you this Amazon thing is bad bad is
exactly about to happen to Title
Insurance in the next 20 years yeah I I
would say that could even be faster what
what what the internet did for
information
the blockchain will do for transaction
yeah
it's really worth both of you and it's
really worth your time to go home in
America
it's a good closing cost it's absurd
it's absurd it's always been absurd I
think the third reason it hasn't changed
is that people options they don't do it
well they're options they also don't do
it regularly options they're sitting
there saying signing all these forms and
paying thousands of dollars for nothing
there's a lot of then it's like okay
whatever that's done I'm not gonna have
to do it again what about being a
merchant giving up four percent of your
money to Amex or somebody to buy
something from you that's not fun my
dad's my dad didn't take credit cards I
got into my dad's liquor store in 1991
1991. I'm 6 15. we don't take credit
cards I'm like Dad
and I was at the register I'm like Dad
do you know how many people leave the
store and don't have a check or cash
yeah and it was like six or seven but
when you're a small business every day
six or seven yeah like that we have to
take credit cards but he couldn't get
over an emotional hump of three four
percent it was meaningful money now it's
just accepted but but what do you think
is gonna happen with blockchain You're
Gonna Take Salon ethereum's got
expensive gas fees but over time
there'll be other blockchains
I mean credit card companies have a lot
to think about there's a lot of people
sitting in the middle
it's a it's a it really truly and this
is why this is so fun I didn't know how
many more when web 2 came I was like oh
this is nine this is internet
but but I wasn't sure like what you know
you don't know when the next thing's
coming
this is so big and what's funny because
of the greed of Bitcoin and nfts what
it's doing is it's a smoke signal over
here and it's keeping people's attention
away from the actual underlining and so
so to me I'm like ooh as an entrepreneur
and as somebody who's got passion to
like take advantage good that selfish
selfish selfless I'm like oh I have a
lot of time because this thing over here
is distracting a lot of smart people
which is going to render a couple more
years of opportunity to land grab
that's what's happening
look back looking
at long terms
correct pets.com
pets.com was 80 billion it didn't have
any Revenue March April 2 every day
since I've been talking about this space
yeah
I've been referencing March 2000. what
with what exactly you just said
but Amazon was four bucks a share let me
introduce
basicallypets.com he knows he follows me
around I I use pets.com and chewy every
day of the week and that's exactly
what's going to happen and it's gonna
happen by the way with nmp projects
right now in this Carnage of 99 that
were made in the last four years going
to zero there is absolutely two percent
Andy Warhol Jackson Pollock Disney it's
just gonna tell take a little time to
figure out which are today
somebody will buy an nft for four
thousand dollars that was forty thousand
dollars seven months ago and it will be
four million dollars in 20 years it
happened today yeah
so that's on that little part of the
world but that is
the infrastructure around entertainment
in The Syndicate syndicated earnings for
everybody yes so it seems to me that the
market that demands
talent scouts Talent spotters at some
time Talent spotters for emerging
artists it was my biggest hypothesis of
influencer marketing of what influencer
marketing the reason I believe in the
NFP thing so much is over the last 10
years I've been very close to what has
happened with human beings monetizing
themselves thank you
for every Logan Paul and Charlie demilio
and people that have gotten famous and
made tens of millions of dollars there's
a long tail of many people who've made
50 to 200 000 talking about themselves
or their passions instead of having a
job the same thing will happen in nft
land that are looking for talent there
will be the people that go on to make
profound economics but the long tail of
having Alternatives I'm so happy for
artists there's a lot of people who
could never make a living painting who
are going to convert into painting on
digital who will make 83 000 a year
instead of being a government worker or
an executive at a retail store will be
an artist full-time live within their
means it's not about billions and it's
going to enable a lot of that it really
is which is really neat you know like if
you think about somebody who's naturally
an artist born an artist the 70s 80s 90s
were not kind to them they had to get a
real job
you think about a kid board today let
this thing went short out for the next
20 years she or he is going to be able
to have a livelihood around their art
now it's gonna be hard even being a
person that makes 80 000 a year selling
nfts will be competitive because
everyone's going to try to sell but if
you look at influencer marketing there
are millions making a hundred thousand
years so many of these markets are are
our winner take on Market
on the platform side
what do you mean winner take all Google
Facebook Tick Tock sorry about on the
individual side no on the individual
side the long tail of creators on
YouTube and Tick Tock is extremely long
it's winner take all if you define
success a million dollars if you define
success eighty thousand dollars
it's astonishing yeah yeah it's
astonishing there's some fix
Ed it's astonishing what's happening
it's not being reported people are not
collecting the data people you have to
be in the day-to-day to understand how
many kids 15 to 45 I use the word kids
that way are making 50 to 100 000 a year
being a personal brand it's very long
tail and as technology and by the way
the Great Recession
has a lot more to do with that options
and I keep telling a lot of my corporate
friends and leaders I'm like you're
worried about the great resignation wait
till you see the great never applying in
the first place you've got an entire
generation of kids growing up on Roblox
Tick Tock fortnite who are like you know
I could work at IBM or vaynermedia or
whatever or I can make 61k doing X Y and
Z I'll live with three roommates I'll
keep building maybe I get to 200k and
and it is a blind spot to The
Establishment at scale and so what we
talk about is these kids are entitled
they're not entitled they're aware of
their options
hey everyone Jacob from Team Gary here
the audio gets a little cut off so we
wanted to remind you what Daniel pink is
saying here he's saying that if he
wanted to start a business that finds
the most promising young people out
there and you want it to buy a small
piece of their earnings early in their
career What discovery method out there
is the most efficient at finding Talent
something came along in the last two
years that did a lot of work for you the
tick tock algorithm
so today I'll explain
five let me break it down for you five
years ago the answer to your question is
great research
if you're asking Spotify and Facebook to
do it they should be keeping the
economics
I've always said this to everybody
everyone's like [ __ ] Facebook I'm like
they're doing it for you right okay if
you want all the economics do it
yourself okay so that's one
my my contemporary answer based on today
is called The Tick Tock algorithm so
Tick Tock why Tick Tock has become the
biggest social network in the world is
because the algorithm was based on the
interest scrap not on the social graph
what does that mean
means as a human being I the four of us
with Dustin might have went to high
school together and we were a click and
at 17 we were a click we're in a small
town together we were a crew and we
followed each other over the next decade
all four of us lives alone our interests
evolved and getting content and by the
way at 27 all four of us are likely in
different parts of our life cycle one of
us might be married one might have a kid
one might really still try to figure
themselves out after adversity one might
be flourishing as an independent
but the content becomes not as valuable
because when you're following people
people are always evolving
that was Facebook that was Twitter that
was the first era of social the graph
that it was built on was who you follow
okay right okay Tick Tock came along and
said we're gonna go about this
differently we're gonna feed you the
things that you're interested in we're
gonna build Ai and technology that knows
Gary's into wine now
but he might be lessened to Wine in two
years and we're gonna show them sneakers
and it keeps pounding interest what that
has done is created a higher level of
Merit and more stickiness people enjoy
Tick Tock so much today because they're
actually getting what they want but why
wouldn't Facebook and Twitter do that
too well they're going they're going to
they're going to but but algorithms are
high tech there's a lot that goes into
that right yeah so nonetheless
itself is young in comparison to the
others social networks
final point to go back to your question
because it's now based on Merit so what
you'll see I don't know if you've done
this before you've seen this or how
close you are to this why is Tick Tock
different if you go to a personal brand
like me or a brand like Nike if you go
to all their social networks if you look
at their analytics most of their content
gets about the same amount of views
because it lives in this pocket if you
go to tick tock right now if you get
curious on this conversation and do a
couple hours of research and you start
clicking around on Brands and people and
look at their tick tocks you'll see
something amazing this video got a
million views the next one got 900. the
next one got three thousand the next one
got 58 000. and so what ends up
happening is you have a higher level of
Merit of the content being the variable
and then if you ladder that up to the
individual it's creating a very
substantial insight to who does the
world like right now
thus rendering the answer to your 17
year old question I know this because
it's what I do for a living and a lot of
the relationships I make are based on
humans that are sending on their way up
and I'm trying to find ways to bring
them value because I've lived that life
and it's good to have relationships with
people that are the Future Leaders of
the world in different categories
so that's the answer to your question my
friend if you start a phone called 17
and did that today I would tell you that
you would have very heavy math Quant
analysts on your team living in tick
tock and then you would and then you
would need socialized people almost like
Club promoters who were charismatic
enough to get the kids to come into your
office because it takes both the Quant
and the qual and then that becomes your
firm
a little bit more
you end up with
you know let's say that I buy the right
one percent I I invested Angela at 876
that would have been smart I
[Music]
because she wants to live in a nice
apartment instead of slumming it with
four of her roommates right right or she
has a br or she has a brilliant idea or
she knows or what I'm trading on every
day she knows who you are and she wants
to make that trade because she also
wants mentorship
see that's an interesting variable but
keep going yeah keep going yeah
economics yep
one percent of her lifetime earnings
could actually I could actually then
actually trade that yes you can I could
you got it I could I could I could hold
that for three now now now
you know what he just said I'm gonna
sell this one percent stake now for I'm
very happy right now for for a million
dollars can I tell you why I'm happy I
think that he's gonna make 100 you know
why I'm happy you're gonna like this let
me tell you why what you just did in
your brain was transition from web 2 to
web3 let me explain what you know what
he did
as a normal BC the way we know it in
investing you kind of sit on that paper
in perpetuity yeah
when it goes to the blockchain right it
becomes a transactional asset yeah so he
can keep that forever yeah but if he
wanted to do the bigger version of what
you did with him because he's at this
point in his life it's a big [ __ ]
thing I think that's a big thing because
do you see this
my Goosebumps
when I it that's how big of a deal it is
you got it this this this but that's
interesting now because you go back to
your VC example if you there are there
are markets where you can correct you
can say you got it but they're very
clergy correct they're very close
whereas this is going to be frictionless
at scale
this conversation for the last 45
minutes is why Zoom will never eat up my
whole life
going to physical places and meeting
contemporaries it's gonna be both I'll
always the cat's out of bag I'm so
excited about doing certain things that
way but this us having this moment
together sharing ideas thinking my whole
career by the way
all the great insights of my life that
have led me down great paths is being on
the receiving end of this conversation
in this moment I'm kind of feeding but
it's interesting hey everyone Jacob back
from Team Gary here we just wanted to
explain to you what Angela is saying
since the audio gets cut out again she's
saying that she's been a part of many
conversations around nfts over the past
few weeks but many of them have been
about the large implications that nfts
in the blockchain will have in our
society for example climate change the
metaverse
ETC or for some reason she believes this
conversation is the most nuanced and
Humane conversation she's had about nfts
yet and she's been grasping it because
she finally understands nfts on a human
level what nfts mean to her as a human
being one thing that I found because I'm
incredibly who I am and so the climate
aspect matters to me tremendously what I
found with 99 of my conversations is
people are headline reading and don't
know the tech they don't know that
ethereum is going to proof of stake
versus proof of work and under that
rendering in August it's deploying less
energy than Netflix so now I ask my
friends who get on their high horse stop
watching Netflix
you know people people are very good at
being selective on but that's why this
is such a cool correct
a hundred percent
you know what's really you know what's
really amazing
you would be you would be flabbergasted
how polarizing the internet and social
media 2095 and 2005 conversations work
what do you mean that's not something
that I remember people had very strong
opinions on 1996-7-8 while the internet
was not only a fad but bad for the world
oh yeah yeah oh come on come on come on
I remember come on yeah again right
because you know you were in a different
place that you were too young for that
okay
okay yeah right it's a valuable it's I
call it wisdom all right I remember the
time when people said it's unbelievable
when you think about it I haven't
thought about this for years this is
maybe 90s
697
well the internet might be a thing but
women won't use it oh that's right
that's right brother yeah about that
like women won't yeah
just a bunch of dudes being stupid yeah
yeah I'd forgotten about that that's
like 96. or less less cliche do Talk No
One's Gonna use it you want to go have
fun go Google the internet is a fad and
read the articles that was so fun yeah
that was so fun listening thank you
it was enjoyable send me those uh send
me those 100 000. hi nice to see you
again great to see you again 2017 17.
yes it's great to see you spoke about my
company that diamond very inspirational
today my husband is here we're starting
an nft project in Romania and good luck
we own a coffee shop that sells uh
accepts cryptocurrency how are they
going to own and use nfts their favorite
coffee shop that sells them seven dollar
latte right the punch card that gives
them an 11th free coffee will be an nft
in a decade amazing and when I released
press release we had only two um two
buyers yeah that's it and everyone
laughs about us yes I said [ __ ] you I
love when they laugh when they laugh you
know it's gonna be good your head yet
yet you know how many orders I used to
get on winelibrary.com in 1995. one two
one two
patience
[Music]
[Music]